lucy is in california hi lucy welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can christy and i help
so i actually just started listening to
you about a week and a half ago
and i started the cash envelope system
and started budgeting because i am a
horrible horrible spender
um so i want to change my habits i do
have a student loan
for about 37 000 that i haven't made a
payment to
since 2017 and
i also have a title loan
that i pay about 96 interest and
my principal balance is about 5 000
um i just because i am
sort of new to this budgeting and i'm
trying to be debt free i just want
your advice on how to attack
these loans that i have because i i do
have a six month old baby that i
want to plan for for her future good for
you
so you're a single mom um no i have a
boyfriend
okay all right so you're a single mom
okay
okay and uh i mean you're not married
right
no we're not married okay and uh what do
you make of your
55 000 okay that's good news
well congratulations on stepping up and
saying hey this is an area of my life
that's caused me pain and i want to fix
it i'm proud of you
yeah thank you very very well done very
cool stuff
good for you so um
having sat in this seat for almost 30
years now here's what i think i heard
you say
in the background behind the words um
how old are you 33 33
okay and so you've kind of just lived
your life and
money happened to you you never happened
to it and the baby comes and you went oh
crap i got to be a grown-up
yeah is that right yeah okay
good for you i'm so proud of you yeah
that's awesome thank you thank you so
much
and i can tell some of that because the
the only way anybody takes out a title
loan is they're desperate
yeah you felt cornered at some point and
out of money and scared
because otherwise you wouldn't have
signed up for 96 interest
everyone knows including you that that
that's not a winning proposition right
yeah no so the great news about your
story is is that once you
once the switch flipped inside your
brain in the last few months
uh and you said no more i've had it i'm
not living like this anymore
you're gonna change things fast so fast
it's going to be amazing
because you're so ready i don't have to
talk you into stuff you're like
over it am i is that right
yes i am okay completely well obviously
then what we're going to do is we're
going to get on a detailed type budget
beans and rice rice and beans no life i
don't want you going out to eat i don't
want to hear about a vacation
you have a mess girl and it's time to
clean it up and we're going to do
our whole life right now is clean up
debt complete focused intensity
like okay
okay all right and the first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna get rid of this
stupid butt title loan and get those
people out of your life and don't you
ever go back on that property
or call those people ever again the rest
of your life
okay i won't i won't ever in fact you
can take your pinky out
and wave it at them as you drive by
every time from now on
because i am never going to go in this
place again they screw people
right no they do for sure and i i know
this because i
am in the financial industry myself but
i
yeah well you had a brain lapse because
you got desperate every time i get
desperate right after that i get stupid
that's what happens to me it happens to
me too and i teach this stuff
so we're going to attack that thing
we're going to be on a detailed written
budget
i'm going to put you into ramsey plus
for one year it's our online access to
everything it's the cadillac the bentley
all right it's going to put you into
financial peace university into the uh
extended version of every dollar the
world's best budgeting app
i'm going to pay for all of it it's
going to be free for you
but you have to promise me you're going
to get in there and do everything we
tell you to do
and one year from today you're going to
have a completely different life if you
do that
oh my god yes
i'm sorry i told you she was ready
didn't i
yeah you're awesome
i am so proud of you so you go through
financial peace university you drag
boyfriend in there by the ear
and uh tell him he's gonna watch it with
you and we're going to start getting our
act together and get our life together
and
get this stress off of you okay you're
going to do this lucy and when you do i
want you to call us back
and you tell us your story and you do
your debt-free scream okay
oh my god yes you're going to we've been
binge watching
on youtube i've been listening to your
podcast and um
he has a sprained ankle right now so he
was stuck with me in my room all day
yesterday while i was working
and i said i'm going to play this
because this is what i've been listening
to while i work
and he's also been so motivated and he's
like wow this just
puts me like in the right mind like you
know and we want to buy
house and want to start a savings for
our baby girl so
i mean i think he's he's better with his
money than i
am but um i'm so ready for this thank
you guys so much you don't even know
how much i appreciate this well we are
honored to help you kiddo it's what we
do
and you hang on kelly will pick up we'll
get you signed up and you call us back
anytime you need help while you're
walking through this and call us back
and
when you score the touchdown and let us
know and we'll do your debt free scream
with you how fun
that is so cool i love that her
boyfriend was a captive audience and
she's like your ankle is sprained i'm
just going to play the dave ramsey
show for you while you're stuck you
can't
leave hey that's going to be our new
answer of how to get people to break
their page
break their ankle hobble them hobble
them and they can't how do i get my
spouse on board you hit their ankle with
a sledgehammer and then just press play
that's great i love it that's awesome
les brown the great motivator i was i
did an event with him about i was
walking through the hallway my picture
with him back here the other day
and i stopped and looked at it because
he's such a good man he lives over in
l.a
and um he just says you have to be
hungry
you know you have to be sick and tired
of being sick and tired
and people change their lives when they
say i've had it
i've had it i've had it and you know
what no amount of intellect offsets that
no no amount of academic discussion of
some
freaking theory offsets that you have to
get this
belly burning thing happening where you
go that's it
i'm not living like this anymore this
sucks
and when you change that that's when it
changes
your my favorite quote of you is you can
wander into debt you cannot wander out
you gotta get mad i love it you gotta
get fired up man
and it's just a decision and that's
where lucy is she just decided
and then we stumbled across her path how
serendipitous thank you lord